on pensait qu'avec la disparition de
johnny hallyday la brouille entre sylvie
20 ans et laetitia les deux ex compagne
du chanteur s'arrêterait il n'en est
rien aujourd'hui c'est sylvie vartan qui
attaquent en lâchant dans la presse une
petite phrase qui ne restera
certainement pas sans conséquence mais
alors c'est du sérieux
bah oui c'est sérieux l'amour c'est
sérieux dans une interview donnée au
parisien la chanteuse qui a vécu avec le
taulier de 1965 à 1980 n'a pas hésité à
s'en prendre à laetitia en déclarant ne
pas vouloir écouter les dernier album
posthume du chanteur une façon de
s'attaquer directement à laetitia qui
est à l'initiative de ces albums ils
sont pour moi les symboles de sa maladie
de sa détresse
ce n'est pas lui dans son énergie son
éclat sa magnificence
c'est pour cela que j'ai voulu le
chantier dans son soleil tu ne veux pas
qu'il soit abîmé une façon très discrète
de remettre en cause laëtitia dans sa
gestion de l'héritage du chanteur alors
sylvie vartan tacle laetitia comprenez
vous la colère
[Musique]
bon alors évidemment là ça alors on est
franchement ça va relancer une énième
fois la polémique
je trouve ça moi je trouve que ce qui
est dommage c'est qu'elles attaquent un
petit peu évidemment johnny parce que
mine de rien kevin faut quand même
reconception contexte c'était donc une
interview pour le parisien c'est une
question qu'on vient poser donc elle
répond à une question ce n'est pas
d'elle même qu'elle a balancé ça pour
connaître un petit peu avoir côtoyé un
petit bustier verte ans et son entourage
c'est pas un sujet sur lequel elle veut
forcément s'étaler dans la presse
aujourd'hui forcément il pose une
question d'un journaliste il veut faire
son beurre là dessus bîmes un buzz et là
dedans avez-vous grohl et sa colère je
la comprends mais en même temps quelque
part elle le dit elle rompt elle-même
hommage à johnny un homme qu'elle a aimé
ça bien été sa première femme aussi tout
ce qui s'est passé après l'image
médiatique qu'on en a à l'image qu'on a
créé autour de ça aussi fournir les
médias ont créé une image autour de
johnny miser aujourd'hui c'est parce
elle se reconnaît pas dans ça et c'est
vrai qu'elle n'a jamais tiré la
couverture à elle bien sûr est bien loin
de celui franche charest alors vous vous
dites molles une main oui parce que j'en
ai marre quoi c'est une énième sortie
alors pas de la part évidemment de de
sylvie vartan mais c'est une énième
sortie sur johnny et je pense que c'est
vraiment celle de trop comme tu le dit
le journaliste lui a posé la question
moi je suis désolé je réponds à une
question et si j'ai pas envie de m'en
mêler juste après je dis bah on peut
supprimer sadly tv mais là j'ai
l'impression que il ya il ya aussi
chacun veut un petit coup de projecteur
chacun à un moment donné va être ce
endredi 0
oui on va demander à un eliane elias
johnny bon groupe on est fier j'étais
assez jeune vous avez 15 ans donc voila
quand woods a de loin ça vous ça vous
évoque quoi
pas grand-chose en foot et non d'un côté
j'ai un avis relatif là dessus parce que
parce que tu as côté ça se comprend
apprend qu'on n'ait jamais l'intention
des gens au fond peut-être qu'à une
histoire d'héritage
il ya toujours l'histoire médiatique
autour après j'essaie de comprendre la
position des deux mais laëtitia a déjà
été assez attaqué depuis que c'était
remis avec quelqu'un donc là une
polémique en plus un sujet en plus
faudrait peut-être laissé jonny empêche
mois magal et foutez lui la paix à cette
province titia un moment donné il y en a
ras-le-bol lamyaghri méjean quel enfer
elle doit vivre c'est un enfer c'est à
dire que à des cafés un truc elle se
fait dégommer je veux bien que ça soit
un an ferme et elle sait si elle est
venue même les petites celles avec la
jeanne n'ont pas arrêté mais c'est
largement je dis non ce truc l'argent
c'est vrai que vous avez une fois l'âge
oui moi on s'enfonce donc à côté mais
c'est vrai que globalement il faut il
faut l'épauler
on va on va regarder on va là d un petit
extrait c'était dans cet ebit malades et
jean claude qui est un qui est un fan de
johnny parce que donné en juin à 61 john
il a passé son permis de conduire mais
la passe et antibes et son logement est
revenue tous les soirs chez moi lorsque
johnny hallyday est décédé jean claude a
posé un arrêt maladie d'une semaine
il nous a fait que du bonheur ça
ce qu'on peut dire de lui c'est sans lui
je sais pas ce qu'on serait vraiment
devenu quoi serait déjà rien qu'on ait
des groupes comme ça on est des amis
c'est la moto c'est johnny cette fois
c'est un ensemble de choses qui fait que
aujourd'hui on a une vie à plus de 60
ans en est on est comme des gamins pour
les fans
alors on encore avec ça vous montrer qui
concerne la tombe de données qui étaient
sympas
donc ça aussi ça fait tout un pataquès
mois unis sur terre et où il veut c'est
clair c'est à s'amasser assabah c'est un
peu loin de la france mais bon voilà
c'est la france est regardée comme les
fans se réunissent autour de la tente
sans avoir
je mets les mecs ah oui alors y'en a
vraiment fait je pense que j'avais que
johnny on se rend pas compte à quel
point ça a été un mentor pour des
milliers de personnes logées incroyable
mais c'est chez je pense qu'on a
rarement vu ça sur un chanteur est alors
encore moins maintenant il ya aucun
chanteur qui provoque cette émotion et
c'est ce besoin des fans comme ça c'est
incroyable ça car toujours c'est pour
les minimales il justement sa sacrée
malheureusement la vérité c'est qu'on ne
se résout jamais à la disparition d'une
icône alors on va avancer parce que on
ne peut pas ne pas vous montrer les
sosies de johnny américains de plus en
plus alors mais moins en moins réussi
mais plus ça va ça passe pour tirer je
t'en fais moi tiens
sa femme sandrine assistantes
maternelles consacre ses loisirs à
coudre les costumes de scène de son mari
elle est réalisée à partir de vêtements
de seconde main dénicher pour quelques
euros dans des brocantes à celle là je
vais vous dire j'ai fait plus de 150
heures de broderie celle l'appareil avec
un pare soleil de voiture j'ai découpé
le pare soleil est gelée cousue sur la
veste est avec moi cd partout avec moi
d'ailleurs même dans la voiture porteuse
g est avec moi ça me demande c'est en
fait maintenant les sosies de johnny ne
sont pas des sosies jeu guégan c'est
plus johnny du tout oui il faut le vrai
c'est johnny c'est mon petit doigt me
dit que vous êtes aussi le sosie vocal
de johnny